this may be your brain on drugs but what
actually happens in the mind of someone
addicted to drugs it all starts with the
brain specifically something called the
reward center one of the brain's goals
is to keep our physical bodies alive and
reproducing so when we do something good
for our survival like eating delicious
food or having sex
our brains produce chemicals that make
us feel good these chemicals are called
neurotransmitters and they're basically
the way our brain and body communicate
with each other the brain produces
hundreds of neurotransmitters but when
it comes to addiction the most important
one is called dopamine dopamine makes us
feel good so we want to do that thing
again and again basically our brain is
training us like we train a new puppy
but learning doesn't always go the way
it's supposed to substances like heroin
or other addictive drugs aren't the
jackpot of the dopamine world not only
do they produce more dopamine than other
activities they make your brain think
that the reward is even better than you
remember so just like that puppy who
wants to sit and get a tasty treat you
want to do more drugs to get that good
feeling over time drug use can also
change other parts of the brain some
connections like the ones related to
impulsive behavior and emotional
responses get stronger and others like
those used in decision-making get weaker
those changes can also cause physical
dependencies if you've ever gotten a
headache from giving up your morning
coffee you've had a minor experience of
what it's like to go through withdrawal
withdrawing for more serious drugs like
alcohol or heroin can cause breathing
problems irregular heart rate and
seizures of course everyone reacts to
different drugs in different ways
lots of people binge drinking college
but most of them won't become alcoholics
and scientists are still trying to
figure out why for all the research
that's been done much of the brain
remains a mystery
you